[Music]
on this Thursday night alleged intruder
the Canadian military member armed and
arrested near the homes of the Prime
Minister and the governor-general grief
grips a small Quebec community in it
just returned late to help the tragedy
that killed three young children and the
former girlfriend of convicted pedophile
Jeffrey Epstein charged Maxwell then
tried to normalize sexual abuse the
disturbing accusations against ghilane
Maxwell plus hockey and how to shut out
kovat 19 when the puck drops hopefully
no one's dropping the ball
global national with Donna freezin
reporting tonight David akin good
evening and thank you for joining us we
begin tonight in the nation's capital
where an armed man was arrested early
this morning near the Prime Minister's
residence the military has confirmed the
suspect is a member of the Canadian
Armed Forces a large number of police
descended on the sprawling estate of
Rideau Hall
that's where Justin Trudeau lives as
well as the governor-general julie
payette investigators say neither
Trudeau nor Payette were home at the
time sources tell global news the
suspect was in possession of several
firearms our Ottawa bureau chief
Mercedes Stevenson is tracking this
story
Mercedes what are you hearing from your
sources about this well David the man
smashed through the gates at 6:30 in the
morning as he mentioned he was driving a
truck which he had driven according to
sources from northern Manitoba to speak
to the prime minister inside that
vehicle sources say were three long guns
including two shotguns and one rifle the
man's vehicle was disabled after he came
through the gates he got out of it at
that point and sources say that he had
one long gun slung across his back and
another long gun in his hands he was
confronted almost immediately by the
police they were able to contain him and
they spent essentially the next two
hours talking him down and convincing
him to surrender they say he made it
clear that he did not have a beef with
the police that the surrender was
peaceful he did not resist arrest
the RCMP especially in this political
climate did not want to have to shoot
somebody if they didn't have to and they
were able to arrest him without that
kind of an incident as you mentioned he
is a member of the Canadian Armed Forces
in particular he's a member of the
Canadian Rangers they're a group that
patrols Canada's remote north
you'd recognize them by their
distinctive red sweatshirts and he did
have those military rations in his car
so that's what we know about him at this
point and I guess the big question
Mercedes is why you mentioned he wanted
to speak to the Prime Minister do we
know what was it that he wanted to talk
about sources say that the man stated he
had lost his job and was about to lose
the
that he used to crash through the gates
he was angry over the current situation
with coronavirus and how the government
has responded sources say that the man
stated he wanted to tell Prime Minister
Trudeau that he did not think the
government was listening or doing enough
to help him and that he's frustrated
with the current situation
David Mercedes Stevenson tonight Thank
You Mercedes an unthinkable Canada Day
tragedy in Quebec has left three young
children dead police say the kids all
under the age of seven were among ten
people who were rejected from a tractor
while riding in its front loader it
happened last night about 60 kilometers
southeast of Montreal in the rural
community of nacho damndest Ambridge two
adults are in critical condition while
others sustained minor injuries and the
driver of the tractor has been arrested
Global's Dan specter is at the scene and
Dan
there's heartbreak and shock across the
community tonight this farming town woke
up in a nightmare residents of the small
communities still coming to terms with
what some are calling an unspeakable
tragedy yeah it is this morning it's
heavy in Notre Dame according to the
mayor of the town it was a family
gathering some had come from Montreal to
join the festivities on this country
road then just before 7:00 p.m. a deadly
decision whose a Canada Day probably
festivity and it just turned like
he'll according to police six children
and for adults piled into the shovel of
a front-end loader all cramming in next
to some wood logs a 38 year old man
drove the tractor onto this road what
happened next
remains unclear but the adults and
children in the shovel were suddenly
thrown out
I could hear I could see the police cars
in the Cyrene's which the sirens going
by so you know as one police and another
than an ambulance and other ambulance so
figured it was something bad when all
was said and done
police say three children were dead
three other children were injured but
authorities say their lives are not in
danger the four adults were also hurt
two are in critical condition and I
thought they went under the wheels of
the tractor the mayor said the 38 year
old driver was arrested it's not clear
if any of the children killed were his
own in farming communities like this
going on joy rides in the shovel of a
front-end loader is not uncommon this
man says he's taken children on rides
like that before everybody does that in
the country but it depends on the
situation they were in do I don't know
but I never heard of ten people in a
bucket the mayor is requesting
psychological help be made available as
many residents here need help to deal
with the emotional pain and shock the
driver is facing criminal charges police
say alcohol may have been a factor david
dan spectre near montreal tonight thank
you Dan a Health Unit in an Ontario
community hit hard by kovat 19 has
ordered a work stoppage at a farm the
move comes after a hundred and
ninety-one migrant workers tested
positive for the virus over the weekend
Abigail Beeman looks at the challenges
migrant workers are facing in this
pandemic and what advocates say needs to
change farm workers can't work from home
when they have hundreds of acres to tend
to promo video from nature fresh farms
in April about getting food to table
during the pandemic but after 191
migrant workers tested positive for
Kovan 19 over the weekend the local
health units stopped work at a
southwestern Ontario farm they didn't
name the facility but sources tell
Global News it was nature fresh the farm
did not respond to multiple requests
from Global News the order is very
specific to the isolation of
asymptomatic and symptomatic workers and
contacts and also the contractors the
small communities of Leamington a nearby
Kingsville are the worst-hit in Ontario
with dozens of farms and thousands of
migrant workers many living in close
quarters 40 people to a bunkhouse
sharing one shower they are climbing on
top of each other to go to sleep
therefore toilets the province is
helping arrange hotels for workers who
need to isolate but a union rep in
contact with some workers at nature
fresh says they're afraid of being
deported if they can't work and afraid
of isolating in a hotel rather than a
health care facility workers like taking
Ontario Premier Doug Ford says they've
sent translators to the region we just
need the cooperation of the workers all
the workers went and hid we were able to
retest three four out of 190 and that's
why my emphasis to the workers nothing's
gonna happen we're here Ontario is here
to help you there are many migrant and
undocumented people who are rightly
scared this needs to be a time of
working together in Leamington Mary
fares husband employs migrant workers at
a greenhouse she says the farmer she
knows are doing their best there seems
to be so much talk about the farmers
being fair to the workers and and yet at
the same time the government and the
health care system isn't being fair to
them at all the premier said Thursday
workers who can't work will still get
paid but advocates say that's not always
happening they're pushing for more
rights for workers like the ability to
join unions and access to permanent
resident status abigail beam in a global
news Ottawa there is now a presumptive
case of kovat 19 in Nunavut which had
been the only region in the country
without one an out of territory worker
has tested positive at the Mary River
mine that's an open pit iron mine in the
remote far north of Baffin Island the
territory's Health Officer says the
individual is in isolation and the
situation is contained the US has
reached another grim benchmark in the
Cova 19 pandemic
the daily number of confirmed cases has
surpassed 50,000 for the first time in
one day the country is now closing in on
three million cases many of them are in
Florida the state set a new daily record
today
adding more than 10,000 Kovan 19 cases
and with fourth of July celebrations
just days away there's concern those
numbers will rise even higher
Jackson prosecco reports like a runaway
train there seems to be no stopping the
pandemic in the US with daily records
for new infections shattered in Florida
and Arizona and with cases now on the
rise in at least 40 states unlike it was
before where it was localized to one
area we're now seeing many major
metropolitan areas that could be facing
the situation of overwhelming our
healthcare capacity it's not just the
result of reopening bars and restaurants
it's the disregard for any public health
advice in Alabama groups of teens were
caught holding coronavirus parties to
purposely spread the virus with cash
prizes as an incentive for getting sick
as bad as things are now experts say
they're going to get worse hospitals are
already overwhelmed in parts of Arizona
Texas and California deaths and
hospitalizations lag weeks behind
initial infections patients first have
to get sick then they have to get very
sick and unfortunately then they succumb
and the crisis is being handled but
President Donald Trump is projecting an
entirely different message claiming the
virus is under control we have some
areas where we're putting out the flames
or the fires and that's working out well
on Wednesday Trump went so far as to
suggest that kovat 19 would simply
vanish I think that at some point that's
going to sort of just disappear I hope
instead it keeps popping up in new
places
less than two weeks after masks and
social distancing were shunned at
Trump's Tulsa Oklahoma rally former
presidential candidate Herman Cain who
was in the crowd is now hospitalized
with kovat 19 though it's not clear
where he contracted the virus on Friday
Trump will visit Mount Rushmore ahead of
Independence Day and despite the
nationwide surge in cases the governor
of South Dakota has made a point of
advertising the fact that masks will not
be required and social distancing will
not be practiced at the event David
Jackson Prosecco in Washington thank you
Jackson and now to a major development
in the fight over the trans mountain
pipeline expansion project Canada's top
Court has ruled against a group of First
Nations who have been trying to stop the
project from going ahead today the
Supreme Court dismissed a new appeal
from three BC first nations effectively
exhausting all options that could end
their year-long legal battle over the
project it is the second time an appeal
has been rejected after the Court of
Appeal ruled in February that the
project would still go ahead this time
saying the government made a genuine
effort to consult indigenous communities
and hear their concerns with heavy
hearts we are here but we know by far
this is not over we have a lot more work
to do we're mandated by our people to to
make sure that this is not going to be
built who that's what we believe it's
not going to be built it has been a long
and bumpy road for the project after
Kinder Morgan backed out in Ottawa
stepped in purchasing the project for
4.5 billion dollars to keep it alive
today the Supreme Court did not release
any reason for its decision dozens of
homes have been evacuated in southern
Manitoba where severe flooding is
threatening to burst an old dam the
situation surrounding Brandon is so bad
authorities are calling it a one in a
thousand year event the little
Saskatchewan River is raging after a
record-breaking storm earlier this week
officials fear a 6-year old dam in the
area could fail that could put several
communities in danger crews are racing
to build a temporary dike disaster
me and mark coming up the powerful
landslide that pummeled into a group of
miners
it was in March when the World Health
Organization declared Cova 19 a pandemic
since then the virus has spread to
almost every country on Earth and it
shows no signs of slowing down the
whu-oh says more than half the world's
infections were recorded in June alone
worldwide confirmed cases are expected
to reach the eleven million mark as
early as tomorrow Krystal guman Singh
has a look at how we got here and where
we may be headed from India to Brazil to
the United States kovat 19 infections
are surging efforts are underway to get
a handle on the dangerous trend the
anyone is suspected
we are taking their temperature their
oxygen capacity the World Health
Organization says the spread of the
virus is accelerating globally it's
renewing its warning to test track and
isolate cases the virus has extended its
tentacles to every corner of the world
members of brazil's military this week
sent masks to indigenous people deep in
the amazon everyone everywhere is at
risk this is not a failure of biology
it's not a failure of Epidemiology or
science it's a failure of leadership in
countries where we are seeing these
kinds of increases there have been
examples of countries successfully
flattening the curve
dr. Santo murse as it proves it's
possible but he and many others are
worried about what's still to come just
take a look how fast the virus has
spread in just a few months in April
infections hit the 1 million mark in May
that number jumped to 5 million and then
at the end of June infection surpassed
10 million there's no use having a
toolbox if your handyman is not willing
to use it
tools such as testing and tracking masks
physical distancing and hand-washing
effective measures that the experts have
been pushing for months crystal
commencing Global News London
just ahead Galang Maxwell arrested a key
figure in Geoffrey Epstein's history of
abuse global national returns in a
moment from Ottawa
you are watching global national at
least a hundred and sixty two people are
reported dead after a landslide buried
workers at a Jade mine in Myanmar miners
were collecting stones at the site when
a pile of mining waste began to slide
into a lake authorities warned the
number of dead is expected to rise as
they clear away the muddy debris in
Brazil raging wildfires in the Amazon
rainforest are threatening the lives of
dozens of indigenous tribes fires in the
region rose by almost 20 percent in June
that's compared to June last year and
that is a 13-year monthly high there's
concern this year's fires could surpass
the devastation caused in 2019 many
forest fires in the Amazon are started
deliberately by illegal loggers and
farmers wanting to quickly clear land
there's been a major development in the
case of convicted sex offender Jeffrey
Epstein his ex-girlfriend and longtime
confidant d'Alene Maxwell has been
charged in connection with his alleged
sex trafficking operation today we
announced charges against d'Alene
Maxwell for helping Jeffrey Epstein
sexually exploit and abuse multiple
minor girls an unsealed federal
indictment accuses Maxwell of helping
Epstein who is Friends of both princes
and presidents to recruit groom and
exploit women and girls one as young as
14 that happened between 1994 and 1997
federal attorneys say Epstein and
Maxwell worked together to make alleged
victims feel at ease and to lure them in
Maxwell enticed minor girls got them to
trust her then delivered them into the
trap that she and Epstein had set for
them she pretended to be a woman they
could trust
all the while she was setting them up to
be sexually abused by Epstein and in
some cases by Maxwell herself the
charges against Maxwell were filed
nearly one year after Epstein was
charged with sexually exploiting and
abusing dozens of underage girls Epstein
died in jail in August last year while
awaiting trial and his death was
determined to be a suicide facing off
against covin 19 next the side effects
of the NHL's comeback most of you are
missing your sports especially hockey
fans but it looks like the NHL is coming
back to Canada at least a Toronto and
Edmonton as the league tries to salvage
the Stanley Cup Playoffs while nothing
is set in stone as Eric Sorensen
explains if it happens the big challenge
will be keeping covin 19 off the ice on
the bleak kovat 19 landscape hockey in
the dead of summer is a bright spot for
Canadian fans and the game they love
great I think it's perfect we need
something to boost us up Toronto's a big
city I think it'd be cool if it came
they came to Toronto Toronto and
Edmonton as host cities would each
welcome several hundred players and team
officials
it wasn't plan a for the NHL which
looked at Las Vegas as one hub to spur
American interest it sends a blunt
message to Washington which has
downplayed the virus that it is
spreading in the US and Canada is safer
this sports marketing expert says it's a
feather in the cap for Canada or coal
bidding for these good numbers that we
have so it's great that we perhaps are
getting a better reward if the NHL can
get hockey started without a coal good
19 disruption then an expanded 2014
playoff would put every Canadian team on
the ice except Ottawa now it may not be
home ice advantage with fans filling the
seats in the usual way but in Toronto
the Maple Leafs will be at home and the
montreal canadiens will be here along
with ten American teams from the Eastern
Conference in Edmonton it's an
embarrassment of riches for Canadian
teams the Oilers would be playing at
home the Vancouver Canucks would be
playing there and the Calgary Flames and
the Winnipeg Jets would meet each other
in the first round the challenge for the
NHL create a bubble around teams to keep
the virus out logistically difficult and
expensive it'll be tricky more than two
dozen NHL errs have tested positive for
Cova
Dean and the Canucks Jake for tannin is
under fire after being spotted mixing
with people in a Vancouver nightclub
it's gonna be the commitment of the
players and it's gonna be really almost
security and some fans seemed prepared
to accept the risk of NHL errs bringing
the virus to town I thought they're
taking like some precaution like like
I'm fine they're just looking forward to
hockey the Stanley Cup Playoffs could
start in about a month
Eric Sorenson global news Toronto and
that is global national for this
Thursday I'm David akin tonight's York
Canada is enderby British Columbia we
love seeing your Canada please email
your photos to viewers at global
national dot-com thank you for watching
I'll see you back here from the nation's
capital tomorrow good night
[Music]